I'm good
so thanks for having here just like them
I'm one of people from the other program
as well and I'll tell you a bit about a
bunch of problems that some of us have
been looking at on optimization under
uncertainty and some of this will have
strong parallels with what Tim talked
about and I'm not going to point them
out one by one but you know you can draw
your own parallels and we can talk about
it offline that's wrong because I
realize I'm the only person between you
and lunch right so good so and it's also
going to be you know this the talk is
going to be somewhat light and so proofs
and technical details but again I can
fill you in offline so the premise is
that you know optimization problems are
often defined on uncertain data and
there's not an audience which needs much
convincing about this thing you know
data might not be available we might
just have predictions about the inputs
the actual data will arrive later you
want to do the work right now so that
you're prepared for when the actual data
arrives or you know the actual data
might not be possible to get you know
it's just difficult it's time-consuming
we essentially have predictions and we
want to deal with it right then you can
write down many other reasons why you
want to look at optimization or
uncertainty so given that what should we
do so this is field of optimization the
field of algorithms has been around for
a long time and people have come up with
various solutions right I mean one of
the solutions is actually you know you
don't deal with it you actually just do
offline algorithms where the input is
given it's it's the stuff that we talk
about in our textbooks the input is a
well-defined set of numbers and you want
to sort them and you know the input it's
precise the output is precise
everything's very nice and I'll call
this a know everything model it's a
deterministic algorithms maybe I should
even say randomized algorithms I'm not
differentiating between deterministic
and randomized in the sense whether
algorithm flips coins or not but whether
the input is deterministic and you know
perhaps too optimistic you know I just
convinced you or maybe I didn't convince
you you needed no convincing that we
need to study
we need to handle uncertainty and then I
give you a model which doesn't handle
uncertainty so very unsatisfying or you
know morning which has been very popular
and successful and beautiful model is
that of online algorithms and just in
case you haven't seen it before here is
a one slide primer about online
algorithms the instance is revealed
slowly over time and you need to make
irrevocable decisions before the next
arrival happens so a bunch of paging
requests happened you need to figure out
which page to kick out of your cache and
this is the sort of this the world
standard out here is the competitive
ratio which says hey you have an
algorithm that's working without knowing
the future it's making decisions on the
fly it has some cost and then you look
back on an instance even before given
instance you look back and you say what
could you have done if you knew the
instance completely in hindsight what
could you have done and this is the the
offline optimum and you compare the two
and you say well what's the worst-case
ratio between the two and if this ratio
is small then you know that your
algorithm is pretty darn good
even if you had known the entire future
you couldn't have done much more than
whatever this ratio is you know this is
this is from Slater and Arjun in 85 when
you compete competing with the best
solution in hindsight so this is this is
a model which is very popular and it's
it's perhaps you know one of the reasons
why we've you know one of the reasons
people have studied this a lot is it
gives very strong guarantees when it
gives positive guarantees but again it
has the same problem that very often it
gives results which are too pessimistic
and then you don't know what to make of
it you know all your paging algorithms
are just as bad in every instance in the
worst case instance in particular so in
that case you don't know what to do and
one of the things and this is in keeping
with the previous talk is that often you
assume something you assume that you
know something about the input you don't
assume
nothing about the future so this is you
know you can call this stochastic
optimization we can call the Bayesian
optimization and that's the main idea
that I'm going to talk about today and
perhaps you can think about this as a
yin and yang thing right it's actually
you know it's more complicated better
know everything more but on the other
hand it's it's a weakening it's a
substantial weakening of the
know-nothing model and you can view it
whichever way you want you know you want
to view it you know either
so for pessimistic thing from the from
here or than optimistic thing from here
that's your choice but I'm just going to
tell you the models I'm going to tell
you a bunch of problems and and we'll
take it from there okay so I'm gonna
just tell you about four problems and
I'm going to tell you the problems up
front and then we'll see how much you
know you how much detail I can tell you
or yeah we'll play by here okay so the
first problem is the problem that Tim
alluded to at the very end of his talk
it's a knapsack problem so knapsack
problem all of you know you have you're
given a bunch of items the items have a
certain science and they have a certain
value in your knapsack has a certain
bound and you want to pack these items
into this knapsack
and this we know exactly how to solve
this an undergrad classes but now the
item sizes are random what are you going
to do
there's a different one you want to
build a network connecting customers the
chief network if all the points you
wanted to connect with known upfront
this is known as the Steiner tree
problem we cannot know what to do but
what's happening is that the customers
are arriving online let's say and each
of them is the random is a random draw
from a given distribution what are you
going to do
you want to find large matching in a
graph but actually you know you don't
really know the edges of the graph in
some sense what all you can do is given
a graph you say okay I'm going to match
these two people and then you find out
whether the matching was successful or
not and this is by the way something
that comes up in kidney exchange it's a
very popular problem right now you try
to match donors and recipients and
sometimes it succeeds sometime sometimes
it doesn't and then you want to figure
out how do you find a large matching in
the graph so and here's a different one
you know you want to serve customers
there's a bunch of people waiting
outside in the foyer you want to serve
them it takes you one unit of time to
serve a customer you you each customer
has a certain value so you pick the
highest value customer let's say the
people who are waiting outside they're
kind of impatient and they leave
what are you gonna do should you pick
the highest value person to serve well
you should you pick the second highest
value person who had almost the same
value but it's much more impatient so it
just gave you four problems I could have
you know and in fact each four of these
I could you know refine in many
different ways I could give hour-long
talks on each of these so this is just
to give you a sense of the kind of
problems where you're interested in
these are all very simple problems on
the face of it but uncertainty causes
these problems to become somewhat more
complicated definitely we can do sort of
interesting things in each of these
cases and I'm going to tell you what we
know about some of these some ideas so
let me let me put down the goal the goal
is to design algorithms that make near
optimal decisions and the near optimal
is just alluding to the fact that some
of these problems are hard
maybe the hardness is due to the
uncertainty maybe the hardness is due to
just the underlying computational
problem being np-hard and I'm given
certain predictions some probability
distributions and we can talk about how
much of the probability distribution do
you need to know do you really want to
depend on the priors or do you want to
be prior independent
in most cases will give approximation
algorithms for these problems in some
cases the the optimal solutions are
known but actually all the talks all the
stuff I'll talk about today will give
approximation algorithms so you should
think of this as you know it's still its
worst case analysis but the inputs are
distributions and I'll try to make this
a little more clear and the sort of
questions that you should ask yourself
are how do you model the uncertainty how
do the solution space change and how do
the solution techniques change because
we really do want to solve these bombs
and and the history very quickly you
know stochastic optimization has been
around since at least the 50s many
textbooks in fact in a lot of great
heuristics and you know those of us
coming from the theoretical computer
science area you know it's natural for
us to try to explain the effectiveness
or come up with algorithms that it at
least worked well in with provable
guarantees and the approximation
algorithms effort of the little newer
and I've put up a few references but let
me not spend time on them let me just
tell you what I'm going to do I'm going
to tell you about the stochastic
knapsack problem it's a well-defined
crisp clean problem maybe I'll give you
a few details about it I will talk about
stochastic Steiner tree which is a
simple network design problem and then
I'll talk about maybe a bunch of little
short things depending on how much time
we have so maybe I'll just go back to
this slide and this pause for a second
in case there any questions about this
so let's let's dive in let's talk about
the first problem so the first problem
is the stochastic knapsack problem and
what's the deterministic knapsack
problem this is something you know
you're given a back the bag holds the
total size of B and you've given your
given items which all have a certain
size and I'm denoting the size but kind
of the height out here and a value and
you want to pick a set of items to put
into your bag so that the total size is
no more than the size of your bag and
they total reward it as high as possible
and we know there's greedy like
algorithms which give you approximations
there is dynamic programming based
algorithms etc so the stochastic
questions are or you know one of the
stochastic questions you can ask is that
the sizes and rewards are random so
instead of the size and rewards being
known upfront they're random variables
and what your input now is is the
distribution over size reward pairs
so what can you do and here's one model
which was proposed about ten years back
is essentially all you are allowed to do
is you're allowed to take an item and
put it in your knapsack and then the
size instantiates so let me show you an
example all you can do
what's the input you're given a knapsack
fixed-size you're given a bunch of jobs
this job is this size but gives you no
value with point for probability and
this size and gives you ten bucks with
point six probability etc jobs might be
deterministic so it's a generalization
of standard knapsack and what are you
allowed to do you are allowed to point
at the job you say I'm going to run this
job the job runs it takes up certain
size it gives you certain value and now
you say what you gonna do I think
another job I put it to and get some
size some reward I see what I get
that's all the information I know you
know the distributions in advance
absolutely
and now you know at this point you might
say okay I'm going to take this job and
put it down you're kind of hoping that
you'll get these sizes but you you're
lucky you get that size you over you've
exceeded your knapsack size the process
stops you don't get any reward just
think of running a bunch of jobs whose
size distributions you know zero over
eight in this case which case was this
so the last item was the failing you get
zero reward for that so every reward
between every job that finishes you get
its world yeah totally good is the
problem clear
so in some sense you know all you're
doing is you're at each point in time
you're kind of resolving the uncertainty
you say you know tell me more about how
much how long this job's going to take
and the only way you do is to by running
with John so you know maybe I'll skip
over this you know you can imagine that
online algorithms are completely you
know you shouldn't compare yourself to
the best solution in hindsight a
solution that knows the outcomes of all
the jobs because hey you know there
could be many jobs you know and one of
them is going to come up with tiny sighs
maybe I'll show you the example you know
there's n identical items each of them
take on a huge size with you know almost
certainly you'd never finish this job
but with a very tiny probability takes
on size zero you will finish this job so
you have n jobs like this with constant
probability one of these jobs will be
size zero so the optimal the solution
which sees everything can pick that job
but you have no chance right all you can
do is just try a job and try job
so what we want to do is you know in
this case you want to make sure your
algorithms performance is compared to
the best algorithm of the same type
which has the same information and
apples-to-apples guarantee that's the
best algorithm good so the best
algorithm is a decision tree like this
it says which job should you try first
and then depending on the outcomes it
gives you the next job to try is the
obvious thing but yeah once you what you
see okay what else could be compared to
yeah I'll be compared to the best
algorithm in hindsight which we don't
want to do for obvious reasons this
seems like a very reasonable thing to
compare actually you could compare to
something maybe I'll come back to this
you could say okay so this you
understand what this is right yeah so
that's the problem like you know I could
find the optimal solution but the the
optimal solution itself could be
exponentially scienced exactly so these
problems for you know those of you who
work in this are usually finite horizon
MDP type problems you actually solve
these things
oh I'm assuming that the distributions
are given in some succinctly represented
way
so you can solve these things given
exponential time but you know maybe we
don't want to do that so a bunch of
hardness results as well and it's easy
to pick up examples where the optimal
decision tree is exponential sized so
then you say maybe I want succinct
solutions so let me just you know
introduce two notion pieces of notation
a decision tree
I'll call adaptive if it's a decision
tree and here is a solution which I
might hope for which is simple to
describe which is just a list of items I
say you know try item one when it
finishes try atom three when it finishes
try atom - and if I run out of time I
run out
decision list if you go and this will
have some value and there'll be a gap
between this I'll call a non adaptive
solution it's not adapting to the prior
outcomes and then I ask the question you
know one question you could ask is what
is the price of a adaptivity how much do
you lose if you restrict yourself to non
adaptive situations and then we could
ask for actually mildly adaptive
solutions you could say compare myself
to the best decision tree of polynomial
size I have no idea how to analyze those
things but there's some work that's kind
of approaching that direction by the way
so the problem clear is the solution
concept clear the solution concept we
want to compare okay so maybe his has an
ideal situation an ideal situation is
give me a non adaptive strategy which
compares favorably to the best adaptive
strategy this would be the best of both
worlds right that's of all worlds I
don't know what both worlds are ok so
here's his 1 approaches is you know the
first idea you try maybe Italy the first
idea I would try is you know I have
random sizes let me assume that the size
of the random the rewards are fixed
there's some complications with that I
might allude to that later on either the
Rhino rewards are fixed each job bias
job of the right size right expected
size
and now this is a deterministic problem
just solve the problem
good or bad yeah terrible expected size
is too sensitive a statistic right I
mean why should you look at the
expectation basically you know here's an
example this bin sizes be always here's
one item which is almost always zero but
with some small probability I will give
you massive size so you know I can make
its expectation anything I want so what
should we do
so you observe that look you know
basically if your size is more than be
the bound that you want it doesn't
really matter if it's you know slightly
more than B or a huge amount more than B
so here's here's something very simple
you know I'll show you only the simple
things you know that this stock has been
chosen you know the problems and the
examples have been chosen to make these
possibly digestible in 40 minutes so
here's a simple idea you know take the
size but truncate it at B plus Epsilon
you know the size went to B plus epsilon
I don't care what the size was that's a
expected size it's a virtual size and
the reward should also be truncated
suitably I'll get a reward only if the
size less than equal to B
we happy with that rain this should be
i'll get reward only the size is less
than equal to B that's the virtual
reward
that's the virtual size and now you use
a deterministic algorithm find a good
solution and there's a slight twist you
almost use this so here's one algorithm
with probability 1/2 try all these jobs
in random order
so this gives you a list just try these
jobs in random order and the probability
1/2 just try to place the best single
job in your system you know for some
technical reasons you have to do one of
the two morally you should just think of
this but actually so morally you should
also think of the fact that yeah
morally you should just think of this
and this was a very nice theorem due to
being gomen symbolic and they showed
that this is the constant approximation
and then it this gets a constant factor
of the optimal reward and the optimal
remember is the reward of the optimal
decision tree so I'm saying you know but
50% probability you just try one job and
whatever you get you get 50% probability
just try the jobs in the optimal
deterministic solution for this one
we're kind of hedging between these two
strategies but both are non adaptive
simple strategies
does this make sense is everybody just
hungry
but questions
so here's a question with me how would
you compare this to the best decision
tree
this is the question that you know
really bothered me at the beginning you
know when I look at this problem I need
to compare myself to the best decision
tree how do I even reason about the best
decision tree it's this exponential
sized human this object the answer turns
out to be simple by the way this was a
non adaptive strategy and the adaptivity
gap is bounded then so how do you
compare yourself to the best decision
tree and the answer is you use linear
programs this is an idea that a lot of
us are comfortable with where we use
this all the time but here this here is
a here is an example so you write down a
linear programming based algorithm so
let me give you a way to reason about
that particular algorithm we our linear
program but actually what I'm going to
do is I'm just going to write down a
linear programming based solution so
I'll say maximize the total expected
reward rewards are constant so you can
imagine that the expectations not there
okay so maximize the reward think of X
is the variable which indicates whether
I was chosen in your solution or not and
such that the expected size and you
should think of this as they expected
truncated size of course that must be
this is a linear program we write down
for knapsack justjust for knapsack or
stochastic knapsack meaning you know the
the the linear program remains the same
the meaning is slightly different X I is
now supposed to indicate the probability
with which you try item I this linear
program you can show captures the
optimal strategy why well essentially
the linear program the the optimal
strategy satisfies the following imagine
one outcome of all the random variables
then the size and this is a particular
outcome of these random variables x
whether you added this to the knapsack
or not it at most B plus the outcome the
size of the last item
because the last item you added but
whoops you went over with the last item
because we truncated the sizes if that
must be as well so it's at most two P
for every outcome this constraint is
satisfied
so in expectation this constraint is
satisfied what's the expected constraint
it's that constraint thanks to but yeah
what's the factor of two so maybe I
should mention all the constants I'll
show all the analyses I'll show out here
not the best analysis possible but again
I'm not trying to optimize constants I
want to give you the general idea so
somehow this LP captures the optimal
strategy in particular I should mention
it captures the marginals of the optimal
strategy this idea by the way is not you
know particular to this example one of
the one of the things to mention was
this this optimal auction of Roger
Myerson and you can view his optimal
auction as basically writing down such
an LP a much bigger LP but the same kind
of LP with variables only for the
marginals is this item allocated to this
person or not the idea of using LP
that's fairly general very powerful and
then what you do is you round this LP
and you get a solution out of it and the
solution essentially gives you the
algorithm from the previous line the
analysis is very simple it's be a mark
of the inequality but you know we're
short in time so maybe I won't go into
that you can extend this to random
rewards and sizes what's the takeaway we
take away is you know the idea is you
know stochastic optimization might seem
like a completely new field but very
often the ideas are very simple oh wow
wow they're very similar to think that
we know they're simple in the sense that
they are not completely out of left
field so you can use techniques that we
know to solve these problems you have to
be a little careful you want to be you
know careful in how you deal with with
the with the random variables and in
some in you know in some nice cases you
can find a non adaptive strategy that is
comparable to the best adaptive strategy
as in this case so basically for the
rest of the talk I will just tell you
about a few problems and maybe try to
convince you that these problems are
interesting and you know there's a whole
bunch of work that still remains to be
done it's slightly different problem you
know I I leave home at 9 o clock in the
morning I need to run a bunch of chores
I leave home at 9 o clock in the morning
I have to do a tasks I have to go to the
bank to the post office to the you know
whatever the shops close at 5:00 and
budget that I have I know the time it
takes me to walk from place to place
what I don't know is when I get to the
bank how long will I have to wait before
my before observed it's a random
variable that have been to the bank so
many times I know the distribution of
this random what should I do
it's brought my new face once in a while
you know it's a problem I'm sure all of
you faced what should you do well what
you can do is you can get a result and I
need a little more time for this so
we'll do this offline I can give you a
non adaptive strategy that in the
beginning of the day you're going to
flip some coins and you're gonna write
down a list of things you're gonna say
I'm first going to go to the bank then
the post office then this then that and
just try this in this order and the
solution you'll get will be kind of
close to the best solution best adaptive
solution and then you can say well you
know this might not be so good right
sadly you know we can also show some
lower bounds this work that Vishwanath
and Nikhil Bansal have done is that
there are problems for which the
adaptivity gap is large so if you
restrict yourself to just writing down
this list of solutions the list of
things to visit in that order you might
get a poor guarantee and a very natural
question is can you write mildly
adaptive solution of polynomial size
that actually gives you a much better
guarantee actually another very
interesting question along these lines
is you know the random variable said the
banks and the post offices they're not
really just random variables they're
little stochastic processes the little
lines out there you know I go to the
bank I see a long line you know maybe I
come back the length of the line should
be correlated with what I saw earlier
depending on the time difference between
when I first saw it and when I second
saw it the two you know the the
correlation should decay with time what
can I say in that case what if travel
times are right now
so on these problems are open I heard
you to try them I'm going to ignore the
approaches for this one the moral I can
tell you we reduce again the problem the
stochastic problem to a deterministic
one it wasn't the most natural
deterministic problem this was a fairly
national problem to solve and again we
found non adaptive strategy it's an open
problem to relate it to the best to find
an adaptive strategy which is pretty
good and maybe yeah I'm looking for P
time algorithms a B P P is fine if
they're allowed to flip coins but I want
a succinct representation of the
solution and I want this to be
computable polynomial yeah five minutes
okay
good so what I'm going to do is
let me try to get to
let me tell you about these couple of
problems oops
I don't know why the massive feedback
out there good okay so let me tell you
about this problem that I particularly
like and has very natural open problems
in there
sorry
see okay here's the problem the problem
that I mentioned at the beginning of
this talk I have to serve a bunch of
customers each of these customers has a
certain value but they are all somewhat
impatient some of them more impatient
than others this person is a saint they
have no desire to leave they just want
to check out the Wi-Fi in this place
this person has a important appointment
they'll leave almost immediately and you
know you see more impatient less
impatient and now each point in time you
pick a customer and you serve them so
you say you pick this customer you get
that value but every other it's not you
the system just crashed Oh excellent
maybe I'll turn off the mic then in that
case okay so you serve this person each
other person flips a coin with the given
probabilities point comes up heads they
leave okay so in this case maybe this
person left these two people are still
remaining you pick another person to
serve other people flip the coins again
they leave so I'm basically imagining a
situation where there's a bunch of
people sitting up around and they have
impatience and they have departure
probability but the model for their
departure
what can you serve what how much value
can get you want maximize the expected
value
so here's what's the strategy the last
what's a good strategy
oh what's the strat suggest any greedy
you can be greedy on two things and try
the first one
greedy on the value just be the person
with the final form of on the
expectation or on the expectation so if
you trying greedy on the value you get a
factor of two because each time you pick
somebody that person might be a saint
they'll stay in the system forever but
instead you missed out on somebody who's
very impatient you could have caught
their valuable so that's a factor and
you can show this is you can't do any
better than a factor of two
using this strategy gravy on the
expectation unfortunately turns out to
be arbitrary back No so in this example
only one person leaves at each point in
time but basically everybody flips their
points and whoever gets heads they
already so if the coins are unbiased
about how some people ugly if you try
you know some randomization you can get
63% if you try harder you can get about
70% but guys I don't know whether this
problem is np-hard I don't know whether
this problem has a you know what I do
know is that this problem doesn't have
simple index policies there is it if you
just assign each person based on their
value and their probability a single
number and pick the person with the
highest number that's an index policy
this jargon your index policy is good no
index policies
index policies could be closed off I
don't know how I'm gonna stop this and I
want to give you a sense of a few
problems with stochastic city added to
very well study profits or problems that
we know and love actually give rise to
very interesting places these algorithms
often we can get algorithms by reducing
to the right deterministic variance but
in some cases connects to a rich body of
work in multiple disciplines but there's
still some new ideas that come in in
particular because we want to handle the
exponential here the fact that we want
to run in polynomial time in very
computer science but I want to go back
to dance questions once you allow
yourself a deterministic optimizing
optimize okay for you know for the
underlying you know if you know
everything you solve NP cook you know
you solve the optimization program so
you have that the municipal isn't hard
but that will somehow tell you what is
the cost of the of the stochasticity
fair enough so I just I think that's
what you're asked good so what you want
to do is you want to say suppose I could
solve the underlying deterministic
problem in polynomial time
no I have an orchid for solve a exactly
exactly
suppose I can sort of map techniques
yeah what can I do so they could not
said I don't know how better than a
factor against even if I had an optimal
solution if you insist on writing down
the optimal strategy then you can show
that for certain variants of knapsack
the form is pspace hard but
it would be nice to be able to assuming
if the approximation guarantee in the
deterministic case with alpha then I can
get you know one point you know one plus
epsilon times out I know this only very
very specialized this good so that's
pretty much it from here it's over